[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL HARTL: Good afternoon,
and welcome to Google's Los
Angeles office in beautiful
Venice, California.
Happy Tau Day, everyone.
I'm Michael Hartl,
founder of Tau Day,
and author of "The
Tau Manifesto."
Today's talk is about
the circle constant.
That is to say the
number that relates
the circumference of the
circle to its linear dimension.
Now I'm being intentionally
ambiguous there
when I say linear dimension,
because the traditional choice
for that dimension
is the diameter,
but that's not the only
choice, as we'll see.
If you make this choice, you
can characterize the geometry
of the circle by dividing the
circumference by the diameter,
yielding the traditional
circle constant, pi.
pi was famously approximated
by Archimedes of Syracuse.
In modern notation, C over D is
approximately equal to 3.14159,
and so on.
But there's something
fishy about pi.
pi writes the
circumference divided
by the diameter,
which gives primacy
to the width of the circle.
But in fact, there are
infinitely many shapes
that have constant diameter.
There's one shape that
has constant radius.
The circle is the set of all
points a particular distance
the radius away from the center.
And this suggests
that possibility
that perhaps a more natural
choice for the circle constant
is C over R. Quick calculation
shows the relationship
between the two, pi
is equal to C over D,
which is equal to C over 2r.
And this factor of
2, as we'll see,
haunts us throughout science,
engineering, and mathematics.
Multiply 2 by 0.2 and you get
that T over r is equal to 2 pi.
If you look back at the original
approximation by Archimedes,
he actually calculated, or
bounds for both C over D and C
over r.
In modern notation, C over
r is 6.28285 and so on.
So in 2010, I proposed
a notation for T over r.
I proposed using the
Greek letter tau.
And this was in an
effort to popularize
what I believe is the true
circle constant in opposition
to pi.
So at this point, I would like
to acknowledge that we are up
against a powerful enemy.
All of us have been exposed
to an enormous lifetime
dose of pro pi propaganda.
I mean, people write
books about pi.
There are whole books about pi.
I mean, people write
books about pi.
A few years ago, a
little internet startup
called Google even
changed their logo
in honor of so-called
Pi Day, 3.14,
in the American way
of writing dates.
In case you're wondering,
this was the final straw,
was the Google Doodle
on Pi Day in 2010.
I thought all right,
enough is enough.
People form a real
emotional attachment to pi.
They connect to it.
They memorize hundreds, even
thousands, of it's digits.
I mean, I know it
might seem crazy,
even to memorize 50
decimal places of pi.
Like who would even do that?
3.14159265358979
3238462643383279
50288419716939937510.
It's a terrible, terrible thing.
So even though we're up
against a powerful enemy,
we do have a powerful ally.
Because the truth
is on our side.
So let's take a look at
some common expressions
in mathematics and see if
we can see any patterns.
So this is the
normal distribution,
this is the density
for a bell curve.
As you can see,
there's a 2pi there.
The details here
aren't important,
just look at the patterns.
Fourier transform, important
in many areas of science
in mathematics, so 2 pie there.
Cauchy's integral formula in
complex analysis, it's a 2 pi.
Gauss-Bonnet formula in
differential geometry,
the so-called nth roots
of unity, it's a 2 pi.
This is one of my favorite sums.
It's the sum of the
inverse squares,
1, plus 1/4, plus 1/9,
plus 1/16, and so on.
In summation notation, we can
write that as the sum as n
goes from n to infinity
of 1 over n squared.
This actually has a
closed form solution.
Anyone happen to know it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL HARTL: Yeah, this
is pi squared over 6.
So that's a pi, right?
Well, it turns out that this
is true for the second power.
It tested true for
a fourth power.
There's a closed form solution,
pi to the fourth over 90,
which might be that you
suspect that anytime
there's an even exponent there
that there is a closed form
solution.
And that's true.
It can be written in terms
of the Riemann zeta function.
Again, don't worry
about the details.
I just like to
draw your attention
to this factor of 2pi.
So even in this case, where it
seems like pi's just by itself,
in fact, there's a
missing factor of 2.
So I'd like to explain some of
the origins of this project,
and it begins with a
mathematician named Bob Poulle.
In 2001, Bob Poulle published
an article called "Pi is Wrong"
in "The Mathematical
Intelligencer."
Now of course, he didn't mean
that pi is literally wrong.
It still has all the qualities
and characteristics ascribed
to it by mathematicians.
It's irrational, and
indeed, transcendental.
But the point of
"Pi is Wrong" is
that pi is an unnatural choice,
because of this factor of 2
that we saw.
And "Pi is Wrong"
introduces this idea of C
over r being one turn, because
as we'll see, it represents
one turn of the circle.
And so, at this point, I'd
like to acknowledge that Bob is
actually here in the audience.
He came out for this
talk, and to meet me,
and other tau enthusiasts.
So, if we could give
him just a brief round
of applause for his work
in starting this thing.
So "Pi is Wrong" planted
the seed for what
became "The Tau Manifesto."
And I noticed that
people were citing it
on places like Reddit and
Hacker News, the kinds of places
that computer, math, and science
geeks hang out on the internet.
But it wasn't really
going anywhere.
It hadn't turned into anything.
It hadn't turned
into a movement.
So in 2010, I set out
to hack geek culture.
I thought I'm going to introduce
this notation, something that's
immediately pronounceable,
that's easy to typeset,
and it has kind of a
visual resemblance to pi.
It looks like pi,
but missing a leg.
It was also influenced
by the choice
of describing this as a turn.
The English word turn is
based on the Greek word
tornos, which means lathe.
And you can see
there is a factor,
there's a tau right there at
the beginning of the word.
So armed with this
idea, this new notation,
tau equals 2pi numerically,
I realized that we also
needed a focus for the
movement, something that
would bring everyone together.
And so it's amazing
how long it took
me to figure out the
answer that was obviously
correct, in retrospect, which
was to take pi Day, which
happens on 3:14, and
launch a new holiday,
called Tau Day, on June 28.
So on June 28, 2010, I launched
the original Tau Manifesto.
And it immediately
struck a chord.
So I took some
screenshots that day.
Someone tweeted
out, hooray for tau.
This breathes new life
into my trigonometry.
That sound, it's
my mind blowing.
Childhood suspicions confirmed.
The circle constant is broken.
Switching to tau immediately.
This guy really get into it.
Do not circles deserve first
class quadratic recognition?
Let us throw off the yoke
of ignorant pi oppression.
So I knew I was onto
something when the next day
I got a bunch of
messages like this.
Oh, no, I missed Tau Day.
So over the course
of the next year,
other people picked
it up and ran with it.
And so at that
point, I really knew
that something was going on.
So Michael Blake
composed an amazing piece
called "What Tau Sounds Like."
I had nothing to do with that.
He just did that on his own.
It's got over 600,000
views as of now on YouTube.
On the first pi Day, after the
launch of "The Tau Manifesto,"
the amazing Vi Hart
released a video.
If you haven't seen her videos,
they're just incredible.
She made a video called
"Pi is Still Wrong."
And it's got over 2
and 1/2 million views
on YouTube as of right now.
Of course, I don't really
these days call it pi Day.
I call it Half Tau Day.
[LAUGHTER]
So this started to take off.
And it started to
infiltrate geek culture
in the way I hoped it might.
So, for example, MIT
changed the time of day
they announced admissions.
It used to be just on pi Day.
Now it's on pi Day at Tau Time.
Tau made it into the
iconic geek comic strip,
"xkcd," with a pi versus tau
proposed compromise to the pi
tau dispute.
[LAUGHTER]
Not to be outdone, another
iconic geek comic strip,
"Saturday Morning
Breakfast Cereal,"
or "SNBC," made this comic.
The father says,
hey, little monkey,
can you tell daddy how many
fingers is this many fingers?
Two finger.
Later, so my two-year-old
calculated that pi tau
conversion constant.
[LAUGHTER]
It's made it into textbooks.
There's a college trigonometry
textbook that uses tau.
And I've gotten lots of
feedback from teachers
in high school and
other levels as well,
saying that they'd use
tau with great success.
It's also made it into some
computer programming languages.
Most recently, a little
niche language some of you
may have heard of here
at Google called Python.
So as of Python 3.6, for math,
import tau, and there we are.
I'm sure many people
here also know
that there's a calculator at
Google, if you drop pi into it,
it'll evaluate it as
3.14159, and so on.
But in fact, this isn't
pi, this is tau over 2.
So I want to find out
who is responsible
for this and by
that person a beer.
Speaking of which,
tau has also spread
to areas that aren't
strictly science and math.
A couple of years ago,
Hawks Head Brewery
in the UK and Crooked
State collaborated
on a sour beer called
Key Lime pi on each side,
but they said you know,
there are two of them,
so we should call
it the Key Lime Tau.
Any guesses what the alcohol
percentage in this beer is?
That's right, 6.28%.
But of course, you can't
take on an icon like pi
without expecting some
conflict and resistance.
So there has been some pushback
on the choice of notation,
to start with that,
the Greek letter, tau.
And there are some
legitimate concerns here.
I'd like to mention a
couple of important figures
who have emerged since the
original "Tau Manifesto" got
published.
One is a physicist in Europe,
named Peter Harremoes.
And he reached out to Bob
Poulle around the same time
that I told Bob
that I was planning
to publish "The Tau
Manifesto," proposing
that we use tau for C over r.
He was completely
independent of me.
And I later found out
that Joseph Lindenberg
wrote a math essay in 1990 or
so on mathematical constants.
And it was obvious
to him that C over r
was the right circle constant.
But you needed a symbol for it.
So at the time,
he was restricted
to the Roman alphabet
and the Greek alphabet.
So we looked through.
He thought, well, which letter
feels most like a circle
consonant and has--
minimizes the
number of conflicts.
Which is the least bad choice?
And he came up with tau as well.
In fact, Joseph now
maintains a website
called Tau Before It Was Cool.
[LAUGHTER]
But there are real conflicts.
So for example, in
rotational mechanics,
tau is used for torque.
In relativity, it's
used for proper time.
I found out after I published
the manifesto, that it's also
used for the golden ratio,
1 plus the square root of 5
over 2.
Now this is the kind
of thing that, yes,
there's some conflicts.
There are only so many letters.
But it's also something
that you can write around.
So for example, one of
my favorite textbooks,
"Introduction to
Electrodynamics," by David
Griffiths, uses n for torque.
Not to route around a conflict,
just that's the letter he uses.
For proper time, maybe you
could throw on a subscript.
The golden ratio has a
standard alternate, that's
probably even more common.
You can use the letter Phi.
But it's also
interesting to note
that the use of tau
for the golden ratio
shows that there is precedent
for using this letter
to represent a fundamental
mathematical constant.
So even though there
are these conflicts,
and you can maybe
route around them,
I think a lot of scientists,
engineers, and mathematicians
underestimate their ability
to handle ambiguous notation.
So I want to show you an example
drawn from quantum mechanics.
Don't worry about
the details here.
You can just look at
the high level patterns.
This is A0, the Bohr radius.
By the way, note that
that's the Bohr radius, not
the Bohr diameter.
And it's a combination
or fundamental constants,
H bar squared over me squared.
H bar is Planck's constant
divided by 2pi, that's right.
m is the math on electron
and e is its charge.
Now so this represents
roughly the radius
of a hydrogen atom in its ground
state, its lowest energy state.
And in order to analyze this
from the perspective of quantum
mechanics, you introduce
what's called the wave function
sine on.
And that's proportional to
e to the minus r over A0.
And so again, this just
describes the system
mathematically.
And what this says is that
it decays exponentially
with a length scale
set by the Bohr radius.
If you've never seen
before, you might
think I don't understand
what's going on here.
If you've seen this before,
you're like I get it.
But there's something
you haven't noticed,
which is the point.
This e and this e
are not the same e.
The first one is the
charge on the electron,
and the second one is the
exponential number at the base
of natural logarithms.
In fact if you
expand out this A0,
you get e to something
with e in it.
I guarantee if you said,
oh, let's use for e
for a mathematical
constant, people
would say oh, no,
you can't do that,
because it's already used for
the charge on an electron.
But in practice, nobody really
has any trouble with this.
So that's all I'm going
to say about the notation.
The rest of the talk
is about the math.
And of course, there has
been some pushback on that.
"The pi Manifesto"
appeared in 2011.
There's a full rebuttal
to "The pi Manifesto"
in an updated version of
"The Tau Manifesto," which
you can check out.
But the rest of this
talk, we're going
to discuss the
mathematics behind tau.
And in order to do that, I want
to return to first principles
by taking a fresh look
at circles and angles.
You may recall from
high school trigonometry
these special angles
are written in degrees.
So zero degrees, 30
degrees, 45, 60 degrees,
90 degrees for a right
angle, and then 120,
180, 270, and then back, 360.
But as you may know,
degrees are in fact
not the preferred way
of measuring angles
in mathematics.
Instead, mathematicians prefer
to use a system called radians.
So in radian angle
measure what you do is
you observe that the
ratio of the arc length,
s, to the radius,
is constant for all
those concentric circles.
And so you can define an angle
theta as that ratio, s over r.
So I'm going to show what
those special angles look like.
You recognize them in degrees.
We'll come back to this.
But I just want to
kind of shock you back
into high school trigonometry.
These are the angles
written in terms
of pi, what I call pi radians.
If you're like me,
you memorized these
in high school trigonometry.
But if you think about what
these angles really are,
what makes them
special, they're just
particularly simple
fractions of a full circle.
So for example,
the 30 degree angle
here is a 12th of the circle.
45 degrees is an 8th.
A right angle is just a
quarter, here's a third.
And finally, all the way
around the full circle.
So that suggests
writing the arc length
in terms of the fraction
of the full circumference
of the circle.
So for a 30 degree angle
that fraction would be 1/12.
For a right angle,
it's a 1/4, and so on.
So if we can plug in to the
definition of radian angle
measure, we can see that
theta is equal to s over r,
but s is FC.
So that's FC over r.
And factor out that
fraction as the fraction
times this dimension
was constant, C over r.
But of course, that's just tau.
So if you are a
believer in pi, I
fear that the resulting
diagram of special angles
will shake your faith
to its very core.
Because this 1/12 of the way
around is just tau over 12.
An 1/8 is tau over 8.
And so on around the rest
of the circle, finally
arriving back at one
turn equals 1 tau.
So to me this is just
a one diagram proof
the tau is the right
circle constant.
There's no way around it.
And if you compare it
to the diagram with pi,
you can see what's
going on here.
What's happening
here is, for example,
at a right angle, that's
a 2 pi divided by 4.
But that cancels, the 2's
cancel and we get pi over 2.
So we have a
quarter of something
is equal to a half of pi.
And that's really confusing.
Indeed I think that this
confusing factor of 2
is probably part of the
reason why degrees are still
the most common way of
talking about angles,
that radians have
never really taken
root outside of these
narrow contexts.
And I think that's probably why.
So I think if you look at
this series of diagrams--
I'm sorry, so conversely,
if we look at this here,
we see that tau to 4
is just a quarter turn.
It has a transparent
geometric meaning.
But it's also just
a number, right?
6.28 divided by 4, 1.57.
So we get all of the
concrete benefits
of radians, while still having
this transparent abstract
meaning.
So I think if you look at
this series of diagrams
through eye of a
beginner, you can
see that using pi instead of
tau is a pedagogical disaster.
It's confusing, it's unnatural.
This is why pi is wrong.
At this point,
more mathematically
sophisticated people are
scrambling through their heads,
like what are some other things.
Like, oh, yeah, oh, yeah,
what about Euler's identity.
So if you've heard
of this before,
you might already
have thought of it.
And if you haven't, well, you're
about to get an introduction.
So to talk about
Euler's identity,
I want to discuss
the circle functions.
So let's look at what's called a
unit circle, radius equals one.
And there's a point here on
the circle with an angle theta
from the horizontal.
And there's an x-coordinate
and a y-coordinate.
And in terms of what they
call the circle functions,
this is cosine and sine.
I'm sure many of you
are familiar with this.
So that point has
x-coordinate cosine theta,
and y-coordinates sine theta.
Now Leonhard Euler proved
an important formula,
an important theorem, based on
these circle functions relating
complex exponentiation
to cosine and sine.
Now Euler was one of the great
mathematicians of all time.
And so you can bet
that if something
is called Euler's
formula, it must
be pretty important, because
he proved a lot of formulas.
So here it is.
e to the I theta equals cosine
theta, plus I sine theta.
So this relates
complex exponentiation
to the circle functions.
And in order to get what I
believe deserves the name
and what captures the true
spirit of Euler's identity,
we're going to
evaluate this formula
when theta is equal to the
circle constant, which is tau.
So e to the i tau equals
cosine tau, plus i sine tau.
We look at our unit
circle, when theta
equals tau, all the way
around, cosine theta is 1--
or cosine tau here is
1 and sine tau is 0.
So that gives us this equation.
e to the i tau equals 1.
And using the idea or the
name that mathematicians
use for 1, when they
want it think of it,
not just as a number,
but as the abstract idea,
we can say that the complex
exponential of the circle
constant is unity.
So the fundamental relationship
between these constants.
And indeed, there's a
geometric interpretation.
If you look in the
complex plane and have
the real part of the number,
of the complex number
z on the x-axis and the
imaginary part on the y-axis,
and then rotate it
through an angle theta,
that rotated point is the
same as multiplying by e
to the i theta.
So e to the I
theta geometrically
corresponds to a rotation
by an angle theta
in the complex plane.
So that means we can
interpret this geometrically
as a rotation by one turn as 1.
So in other words, if you
rotate by a full turn,
you just get back to
where you started.
And that's the same
thing as multiplying
by 1, which does nothing.
So I submit that
this is at least
a candidate for the
most beautiful equation
in mathematics.
Which brings me to
what I think is not
the most beautiful equation.
Which is Euler's formula
evaluated when theta equals pi.
So again, looking at our circle,
when theta equals halfway
around the circle, cosine pi
is negative 1, sine pi is zero,
and we get e to the i
pi equals negative 1.
But there's something
fishy about this formula.
What's going on with
this negative sign?
It's so ugly.
In fact, this is almost
always rearranged immediately
to form e to the i
pi plus 1 equals 0.
At which point, the expositor
usually says something mystical
like, ooh, this formula
connects the five most
important numbers in
mathematics, 0, 1, i, e,
and pi.
But is this really the
most beautiful equation
in mathematics?
I mean, I don't know.
There's a negative sign,
and we had to rearrange it.
What's really going on here?
Well, we can find out by
rewriting the Euler's identity
traditional form
in terms of tau.
It's e to the i tau over
2 equals negative 1.
No rearrangement.
What's going on here?
Well, what's going
on here is that it's
a rotation by tau over 2.
So here's a point in the
complex plane, a plus ib.
X-coordinate a, y-coordinate
b, and if we rotate it
around half a turn,
we get this point,
at negative a, and negative b.
So that's just
negative a, minus ib.
We factor out the negative 1 to
get negative 1 times a plus ib.
But that's just
negative 1 times z.
So in other words, what
this equation is telling
us is that a rotation by half
a turn in the complex plane
is the same as
multiplying by negative 1.
So the original form
of Euler's identity
has a transparent
geometric meaning
that's obscured when we
write it in terms of pi.
So I believe this really ought
to be called Euler's identify.
People do have a tendency to
get all numerological about it
though.
And it's amazing how many people
complain that this formula
relates only four numbers.
So in this context, I would
like to note that e to the i tau
equals 1 plus 0.
So I assert that this
equation actually
does unite all of the most--
the five most important numbers
in mathematics, 0, 1, i,
e, and tau.
So if you arrived here as a
pi believer, surely by now,
you must be
questioning your faith.
Is there no iconic
famous equation
that has just a pi by itself?
Can anyone think of one?
What's a famous equation
that just has a Pi?
AUDIENCE: pi r squared.
MICHAEL HARTL: pi r squared?
It's true, the
area of the circle.
So that is just a pi by itself.
So circular area would seem to
present a challenge to the tau
world view.
Should I be worried?
I don't feel worried.
So let's take a look
at circular area
and see how it's related to tau.
So here's the equation,
A equals pi r squared.
It's a very famous,
iconic formula.
But there's [? something ?]
fishy about this formula.
What's fishy about it?
Why the sudden love
for the radius?
I thought circles were
about their diameters.
We're dividing out
by D. So we really
should write this, in
order to be consistent,
as A equals one quarter pi D
squared, which isn't nearly as
pretty.
All right, so let's figure out
what's really going on here.
Let's look at this expression.
I want to draw your attention
here to the power of 2.
That second power makes
this a particularly simple
quadratic form.
The name mathematicians use
for this kind of expression.
Now I want to show
you some examples
of the kind of patterns
that quadratic forms follow.
And for this, I'm going
to draw on my background
of theoretical physics.
I have a PhD from Cal Tech.
And when I was a
graduate student,
I taught the physics core
curriculum for five years.
And I'd like to show you some
examples of quadratic forms
that arise in the elementary
physics curriculum.
It's not necessary to
understand all the details here.
Just look for the
high level patterns.
We're going to start with a
calculation for the distance
an object falls in a
particular amount of time.
So Galileo Galilei found
that the velocity of a
dropped object is proportional
to the time it's fallen.
So if it falls twice as
long, it goes twice as fast.
The constant of
proportionality is
the gravitational acceleration
G. In this context,
the velocity can be defined
as the time rate of change
of the height, dy dt.
So we can find the distance
fallen by integrating V dt.
Which is the integral of G
dt, with G as just a constant.
We can pull it out.
The integral of t
with t squared over 2.
So y is equal to 1/2 Gt squared.
We can also look at
the potential energy
in a spring, another
common thing that
shows up in the elementary
physics curriculum.
Robert Hooke showed that the
force that a spring exerts
to restored equilibrium
is proportional
to the displacement
from equilibrium.
And the cause of
proportionality is essentially
a measure of the
stiffness of the spring,
is the spring constant k.
And the potential energy
is equal to the work
done by the spring force, as
you compress it or stretch it.
U is equal to integral of Fdx.
Integrate the force
over the distance.
So you say U equals Fdx, and
Fdx equals integral from zero up
to the final displacement
of kx dx, which
is equal to 1/2 kx squared.
And finally, I want to
show you the calculation
for the kinetic energy, one of
the most important quantities
in mechanics.
Isaac Newton found
that the force
is proportional to
the acceleration.
The concept proportionality
is the inertial mass n.
This is the most famous
expression of Newton's Second
Law of Motion, f equals na.
Now the kinetic energy is
equal to the amount of work
done accelerating a mass m
up to a final velocity of e.
So that's the integral of the
force over the displacement
again.
So k is equal to
interval of Fdx,
but the force is mass
times acceleration.
Acceleration is the time rate
of change of velocity, n Dvt.
Now Newton would be
unhappy at this point
because we are using the
notation of his hated rival,
Gottfried Wilhelm von Leibniz.
But one of the great things
about Leibniz's notation
is that you can manipulate these
little differentials, these Ds,
as if they were fractions.
So we can write Dv
Dt Dx as m Dx Dt Dv.
We can just swap
the Dx and the Dv.
But this here is
just the velocity.
So this is the
integral from zero up
to the final velocity of
m Dv, or 1/2 m Dv squared.
So just to review, distance
fallen, potential energy
in the spring, kinetic energy.
You may by now have a sense
of foreboding as we return
to the geometry of the circle.
Let's calculate the
area of a circular disk.
We can do that by breaking
the disk into rings of length
equal to the circumference of
that radius and thickness equal
to Dr. So the area
is circumference
times the thickness
of that ring.
Now the circumference is
proportional to the radius.
Constant proportionality is tau.
You can calculate the
area of the circle
by integrating
over all the rings.
So a is equal to integral Da,
equals the integral of CDr,
which is the integral from zero
up to the final radius of tau
rDr, which is 1/2 tau r squared.
Indeed, in the original proof
by Archimedes of Syracuse,
he showed not that the
area was pi r squared.
Archimedes didn't have
modern algebraic notation.
What Archimedes proved was
that the area of a circle
is the same as the area of
a right triangle with height
equal to the radius, and base
equal to the circumference.
We can then apply the formula
for the area of a triangle,
area equals 1/2
base times height,
as a equals 1/2 bh, equals 1/2
Cr, equals 1/2 tau r squared.
There's simply no avoiding
that factor of a half.
All right, I've been
doing this a while.
So as you might imagine,
I've fielded a lot
of questions over the years.
So this is just a few of
the most frequently asked
questions.
One question people ask is
won't tau confuse students
if they already know about pi.
This is too complicated.
So in this context, I'd like
to show you a tau testimonial.
I'm sorry, surely I
mean a taustimonial.
I'm not going to
read the whole thing.
But I just want to give
you the background here.
There was a student,
who at the time,
was an undergraduate at
MIT, was trying to help
his sister, who
was in high school,
with an upcoming
trigonometry exam.
And she was really struggling.
So he was showing her
everything the standard way.
And finally he said
no, no, screw this.
I'm going to do this
the correct way,
and he switched to using tau.
And she grokked it,
using the term grok
from Robert Heinlein's
"Stranger in a Strange Land"
to indicate that she
really understood it.
When the test came, her
strategy for the test
was to do every problem
with the tau circle,
and then to sweep
over it at the end
and convert every tau to 2 pi.
She was the first
one in her class
to finish the test with 100%.
So in fact, tau is much
less confusing than pi.
I also think it's worth
noting that the idea that pi
might be wrong is interesting.
So this is a way
of hooking people
into having an
interest in a subject
that some people might
consider a little dry.
Another objection that
people raise is say well,
isn't it too late to switch.
They tell me, OK,
like, I kind of get it,
but wouldn't we have to
rewrite all the textbooks.
And the answer is no.
We just saw that you can
make a change inferentially.
You can always
substitute tau into pi
for each other mechanically.
So there's really no need to
make the change all at once.
If you're trying to
redefine what pi means,
then it would be hopeless.
But this can be an
incremental change over time.
And as we saw, there's already
a textbook that uses it.
So the second to last
question is alarmingly common.
And so I'll allow
Natalie Portman to ask it
on behalf of everyone else.
Thank you, Natalie.
No, I'm not a crazy person,
apart from my usual shirt,
I'm practically
normal in every way.
You'd never guess from
looking at me on any other day
that I'm anything other
than a normal person.
You'd never guess
that I'm in fact
a notorious mathematical
propagandist.
But I think when people ask this
question what they really mean
is that this isn't like
your full time thing, right?
You're not like a full
time tau activist.
No, I do other stuff.
I'm actually the
author of a bestselling
book on web development, called
the "Ruby on Rails Tutorial."
There's an overlapping audience
for these two products,
for "The Tau Manifesto"
and the "Rails Tutorial."
So every once in a while
someone will tweet out,
saying, oh, my god,
I just realized
that the author of
"The Tau Manifesto"
is the same as the author
of the "Rails Tutorial."
Like what?
They're slight different in
tone, as you might imagine.
And this has now become part
of my current venture, which
is an educational
products company, called
Learn Enough to be Dangerous
at learnenough.com.
So this is not my full time gig.
I do other stuff.
All right, the final
question, it's important.
It seems lighthearted.
But I really feel
like it captures
something essential for any
sort of movement like this.
But what about puns.
Right pi is fun.
It's like pi in
the sky, pi around,
we have this tasty dessert.
And this was actually one
of the things about tau
that I was really pleased
about, when I realized,
you know what, there's a lot of
potential here for making puns.
And if you're going to try to
insert this into geek culture,
that matters.
So for example, we can
see here's the tau.
We're all Tauists.
So what I've done
here is I've taken
the traditional symbol of
Tauism, the yin yang symbol,
and rotated it.
How far?
I've rotated it a quarter
turn, or tau with four radians.
So what is this?
Is this pi?
This is yang.
This is only halfway around.
We have to go all the
way around to understand
the true nature of the tau.
And so using pi instead of tau
is like having yang with yin.
And we can relate this
to Euler's identity
by noticing that e
to the i tau equals
1 says be one with the tau.
A rotation by one turn is 1
may sound like a tautology,
but in fact, it is the
true nature of the tau.
Finally, even as we contemplate
tau's mystical implications,
we must remember that Tauism is
based on reason, not on faith.
Tauists are never Pious.
So I hope you'll join
me in celebrating
the true circle
constant, C over r,
and I hope you'll also
join me in calling it tau.
I'd like to leave you
with some words of wisdom,
some words that have a great
deep and personal meaning
to me, and I hope they'll have
a meaning for you as well.
Those words are 6.
2831853071795864769
2528676655900576839 4338502116.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]